[Laughter]
hey i'm alex so today i'll be testing
and reviewing the ninja air fryer maxxl
we'll be seeing how well it works if the
food it makes taste good especially in
comparison to a conventional oven and if
you should consider buying it yourself
so today we're going to be testing out
some french fries and some chicken
tenders to see how well this airfryer
works all right let's fry away
[Music]
alright let's crack this baby open
oh my god it looks like a spaceship or
something
all right i'm just gonna rip this thing
open beautiful
it looks really nice actually
there's a little mirror on top
looking good
looks like it's pretty straightforward
and it tells you the cooking times for
looks like chicken fries
steak a cupcake for best results reduce
cook times and shake food often
oh there we go
so this is like the contraption
that i'm guessing you put the food in
we've got a little bit of like a baking
rack here
that should be nice probably for good
like airflow getting all around seems
you know pretty straightforward well
it's all looking pretty promising i'm
excited so let's get cooking ninja
so we're going to be cooking a pound of
fries which is about half of this bag it
says here that frozen fries will go on
max crisp for 13 to 16 minutes it also
mentioned in the book that you need to
preheat
the air fryer there is no preheat button
on here so i'm just gonna add three
minutes to the cook time get it going
and then i'll pull it out and we'll
start the cook time i'm gonna go for
about 15 minutes total
because that falls a little bit in the
middle so let's turn this baby on max
crisp it's at 450. i'm just going to
make sure
you can push the time up so
if we're going for a 15 minute cook i'm
gonna start it at 18 minutes because we
get a three minute preheat
and start okay
we're on it's making some noise mirrors
not doing anything still looking good
now the vents are going i feel some air
for sure i feel like this is pretty well
protected though so i don't feel like
this will get too hot which is nice so
we're almost there i wonder like i guess
i should open this now we're gonna pull
the basket out and
put these fries in there
okay
oh it's definitely hot so about half the
bag
starts right up again so we'll check
back in five minutes and give a little
shake a little fresh egg
all right we're five minutes down i'm
smelling the fries already i'm gonna
take them out and give them a little
shake
they they almost look like glossy from
oil that's so interesting so just shake
them up shake shake shake
shake your eyes
in a normal oven bake this would take 22
to 24 minutes to heat through so we
actually have a batch of fries in the
oven so we can compare but i love this
thing i want to take this one home he's
my new best friend alright so in a few
minutes we'll give it one last shake and
then we'll finish them off and see how
they fried
check them out now i'm going to put it
back in for the final fry
5 minutes 30 seconds on the clock
all right we're about 30 seconds away
from these fries being fried
i'm excited i hope there's like a nice
little tune that plays or something oh
no i'm nervous
no song
they're crispy though you hear that
we'll plate these babies they're looking
pretty good they seem pretty crispy i'm
gonna hit these with a little bit of
salt i like my fries pretty salty looks
like a good amount of color on there i
have to say definitely got golden brown
i like that
it's a good fry
crispy fried
hot
the center is hot
crispy outer
edge that's all you can really ask with
the fry right so i think these are
pretty good but let's get our batch from
the conventional oven to see how they
compare and i'm also going to have a
special friend come and help me try them
all right we've got our two batches of
fries all i need now is my special
friend hello i'm your official friend do
you know what this food is yes
french fries
one of the batches was made in this air
fryer and another one of batches was
made in an oven okay so i'm gonna
salvage this yeah
you like ketchup i loved it
this is crunchy outside i kind of like
it already
oh i think you just do the comparison
it's still hot
yeah
it's kind of both same
it's gonna be kind of the same they're
kind of the same yeah it's so subtle i
cannot tell you which one would you say
is crispier i think outside is a little
bit crunchier but it's very similar
honestly it's a tie to me i have to say
i'm slightly disappointed
just because i really had really high
hopes for this i didn't want it to tie i
just like really wanted
amazing results yeah thank you ria thank
you for your friend
why did baby
baby like the fries
all right for our next test we're going
to try to make some air fried chicken
tenders we're going to be comparing our
air fried chicken tenders to a classic
deep fried chicken tender but first
things first let's spread these bad boys
so i'm just gonna hit my chicken with
some salt and pepper
give that a little mix
straight into the flour
shake off excess into the egg and then
into the panko so i think this is going
to be the ultimate test because with the
fries we just did a bake versus air fry
comparison for this we're doing a
full-on deep fry versus air fry
comparison
and
deep frying can be pretty intimidating
for people so
if this works and is as good or better
than the deep fried chicken tenders
i'll give this a win i'm gonna tee up
the air fryer to preheat starting
now
i was really hoping there would be some
sort of song like a little beep beep
song like a do
do do
we just have fried bees or something
sadly there was no song on this one but
you know what maybe i'll make my own
airfryer and it'll have all my noises
that i make in life
i'm gonna go ahead and give it a little
spray just to maximize our crispiness
here
okay i'm also gonna be using this rack
just so we can maximize the layer
of chicken because we actually don't
have too much space in here this isn't
using a little points to the oven just
because you can do a lot more in the
oven but to be fair you can't crowd a
deep fryer either
all right and we go unlike the fries we
are not shaking these babies so i'm just
gonna let it go for the next 12 minutes
see you in a few ninja all right we've
got five seconds five
four
three
two
[Laughter]
i made my own song
oh
okay they moved they moved to the other
side of the rock what happened probably
like when i shoved it in there
interesting first thoughts
not like a perfectly golden brown
all the way around type of deal some
spots are clearly darker than others
which kind of is like an uneven cooking
situation definitely looks more like an
oven baked chicken tender
than like a deep fried chicken tender
deep down we're getting even less color
like
i think they're cooked through but it's
just like there's not much browning
going on definitely the top ones got way
more brown to be safe i'm just gonna
check the temperature we're at like 180.
so it definitely cooked through
but
definitely some differences in color
versus the top and bottom they smell
good though
all right we've got our tenders on the
plate we've got our friend air2d2 time
to try it i'm gonna go for one of like
the crispier ones
give a little ranch dip
[Music]
i'm not bad
i have to say the chicken is a little
dry like it might be a little overcooked
but it's a good crispiness on the
outside considering we didn't use any
oil i'm gonna try one of the bottom ones
this one's a little juicier for sure but
you don't have the golden brown crispier
you kind of like gotta choose what what
you value more the juice or the crisp
well what are we gonna take i kind of
like hesitate bringing these out
but these are the deep fried ones
definitely the real deal obviously
there's a big color difference here but
we cook these in oil so there's that
although they don't have the color like
the crispiness is still there on both it
just like
looks can be deceiving
i'm gonna give the deep fried one a try
it's really good
the chicken is juicier i don't know it's
a tough call you know these just look
better they taste better
i gotta go with the deep fried version
but here's the thing a lot of people
don't like deep frying it's it can be
hard it can be scary so you still can
get a good crisp with there and it
tastes alright yeah it completely does
all right both of our tests are done
let's break it down did the airfryer
work yes was it easy
yes the instructions were easy the timer
works the modes are great it's fairly
straightforward the food tasted good was
i expecting more
yes so the air fried fries were just
about the same as the oven baked version
the pre was quick but the overall cook
time was pretty similar the chicken
tenders also worked but they weren't
that much crispier or much different
than a baked version and then when you
compare them to a deep fry there really
is no competition except for maybe
health-wise this is just like a mini
oven i guess
so we paid a whopping 140 bucks for this
guy and if you for some reason don't
have access to an oven i guess this
might be your best bet but if you do
have an oven and are cool with using it
i would just say stick to your oven
140 bucks that's a whole gym membership
so deep fry and then just go to the gym
you know as much as i would love to give
our old boy air2d2 a whopping two thumbs
up
i knew
this guy we're hitting in the middle it
didn't really live up to the hype i i
really had this up in my mind though so
maybe that was my mistake also it didn't
have a song and i will always go back to
that
all right well that's it for this one
let us know in the comments if you want
us to review anything else or if you
have an air fryer and how you like it
other than that i'll see you next time
good fry
ninja oh yes
[Music]
bye